go ahead and draw a small diagram it
doesn't have to be beautiful but it does
have to be big enough that you can do
some thinking on it okay and I'm gonna
add a construction here in a second so
the reason I know this can't be they
can't intend me to talk about compass
bearings North ASTs north east south
west is because look at the size of the
angle 33 do you see it's an awkward
number it's awkward it's not a right
angle of anything it's not even 45
degrees off anything it's not even
twenty two point five degrees of
anything it's just it's random we're out
in the middle of nowhere so therefore
the only way when they say please give
us the bearing is to use this system
here shoe bangs okay when I measure true
Barry where do I start from
I always start from North so you can see
that's why this angle is here this angle
is really large because it has to go all
the way around okay so like you two with
you if you've got another color that
would be nice
marking the starting point up from here
on north and then go all the way around
until you get to the desired position I
think they're calling the starting point
oh and you're measuring to pee okay I
was in the middle I think they just made
the point so it could be anywhere okay
now let's have a look at this
there's a least a few different angles
we have to measure in here for instance
every time you go through a quarter
rotation a quadrant that means ninety
degrees right do you agree 90 up there
98 down you what's this little one it's
not a full 90 degrees it's gonna be 57
it's the complement of 33 do remember
that word complement they add up to a
right angle 90 degrees
okay 180 is a supplement so I've got a
total angle there 90 90 57 what's the
bearing
what's the barrier 237 degrees true now
underneath here just for this question I
won't ask you to do it for the rest but
now is a perfect opportunity to point it
out I want you to note language because
this is a really tricky thing especially
some of the harder questions after 237
degree is true could you please write
for me is the bearing dot dot dot and
now there are two ways I can say it I
can say of P from Oh
or I could say from o to P these mean
the same thing even though the order is
different you can see it's these tiny
little connecting words these guys of
from from two they're the ones that
indicate the meaning because the bearing
from P to O is different think about it
it's a different question the question
hasn't asked you but I'm asking you now
if I wanted to find the bearing from P
to O and raschi draw the second go
you're gonna need a new little compass
over here right we're gonna have a look
at this have a look where is the bearing
from P to Oh where do you always start
from what direction do you start from
you always start from north
so here's North up there and you're
going to measure this angle over here I
apologize that so small I should have
made my diagram bigger as well what
bearing is that can you see a little
construction it's actually not 33 it's
related to 33 though
okay pause for a bit first remove it Shh
I've heard them I've had some right
answers and right answers Leah I'm less
interested in the number and more
interested in why I can give you two
reasons why the answer is 57 here's my
first one see this angle here
do you notice it's related in a very
specific way thick all the way back to
you seven with this angle what's the
relationship between those angles they
are alternate angles on because every
North line is facing in the same
direction does that make sense okay so
that's the first thing there's another
way you can know it have a look at this
imagine if I just extended that line up
it's a North line yeah what's it
colliding with what line is this it's a
West line so these lines are
perpendicular to each other they're at
right angles which means up in here
there's a triangle there you can find
out the angle sum you'll still get 57
okay so this is super super important
these words are so tiny but we know I've
mentioned it to you all here
mathematicians are so obsessed with
packing lots of meaning into a very
little space and being succinct that
just a difference of two letters changes
the answer entirely 57 degrees versus
237 okay so read the question carefully
is what I'm trying to indicate to you